bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
l'équipe de france de football fait ses
valises en silence les joueurs
quitteront l'afrique du sud ce soir
florent malouda est parti le premier
sans dire un mot nicolas sarkozy
s'empare du dossier il recevra thierry
henry demain à paris invité ce soir rama
yade secrétaire d'état aux sports c'est
sa première intervention depuis la
déconfiture des bleus bonsoir ça et à
tout à l'heure
une nouvelle information embarrassante
pour eric woerth dans l'affairé
bettencourt en 2008 il avait remis la
légion d'honneur au gestionnaire de la
fortune de la milliardaire
un lequel venait d'embaucher son épouse
tout s'est fait en transparence répond
le ministre l'épreuve de force après l
annonce de la réforme des retraites la
grève a commencé ce soir et pour 24
heures force de perturbations attendues
demain à la sncf à la ratp est sans
doute à l'école primaire
les syndicats espèrent lancer la
mobilisation adieu petits fours et bains
de foule la traditionnelle garden party
du 14 juillet à l'elysée et supprimé une
décision qui se veut symbolique en ces
temps d'austérité et de polémiques aussi
sur les avantages des élus ou des
ministres l'inde est fait la nation la
plus peuplée du monde le pays dans un
gigantesque recensement pour conter une
population encore mal connu qui nous
irons sur place et puis la france
interdit officiellement la fabrication
et la vente de biberons en plastique
contenant du bisphénol a depuis des
années les scientifiques s'interrogent
sur l'implication de ce composant
chimique dans des maladies graves
bienvenue dans ce journal
motus et bouche cousue donc en attendant
peut-être le grand déballage annoncé
l'équipe de france est restée
silencieuse et même invisible
aujourd'hui en afrique du sud pour les
explications il faudra donc attendre un
peu les joueurs ont quitté l'hôtel tout
à l'heure ils prendront l'avion dans
quelques minutes
à paris nicolas sarkozy prend l'affairé
en main ils réclament des états généraux
du football
antoine gaveau mathieu garden pour le
moment il est le seul à être dans les
airs florent malouda a pris l'avion cet
après midi avant ses partenaires
pour retrouver sa famille et son enfant
qui vient de naître flora ce n'est pas
encore l'heure du grand déballage
mais face aux journalistes il ne dit pas
un mot ni sur les bleus ni sur son
avenir en équipe de france
joran amour pour les mots justement la
ministre de tutelle de l'équipe de
france les a trouvés et cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
il était très dur je ne peux que
constater comme vous j'ai jean françois
lamour le désastre le désastre avec une
équipe de france où des caïds immatures
commandent à des gamins apeurés une et
qui a coaché désemparé et sans autorité
une fédération française de football aux
abois
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a décidé de prendre toutes
ses responsabilités
un peu plus tard à l'elysée réunion de
travail entre le chef de l'état françois
fillon roselyne bachelot et rama yade
le président a souhaité des états
généraux du football en octobre et
qu'aucun avantage financier ne soit
versé à l'équipe de france
mais à l'ump certains députés veulent
aller plus loin et faire signer aux
joueurs une charte une condition pour
porter le maillot bleu
ils sont les représentants du peuple
français car ils sont sélectionnés dans
l'équipe de france a sauté il se
comporte comme des français ils
défendent les valeurs de la république
ils se battent y mouille le maillot et
ils ne font pas des pitreries comme on
l'a vu récemment ce matin à la
fédération française de football on
enlevait les portraits des joueurs
passer en quinze jours d'icônes géante à
deux simple boulette de papier avant
d'aller lisez avant d'aller à l'elysée
entre aux manuels tissier en direct à
l'aéroport de george en afrique du sud
bonsoir manuel les joueurs sont attendus
d'un moment à l'autre ils ont donc été
discrets aujourd'hui où effectivement le
bus va dans quelques instants arrivé ici
au milieu d'une force de police
importantes et des journalistes
effectivement ils ont préparé les
valises toute la journée et on les a pas
vu pas entendu à l'image de florent
malouda tout à l'heure qui n'a pas dit
un mot
les bleus sont restés au secret secret
comme leurs plans de vol vers la france
qui n'a pas été révélée publiquement on
sait simplement qu'il vont arriver au
bourget demain matin et qu'il devrait
faire escale à paris
de georges ici sans doute à cape town
pour les formalités douanières mais on
n'a eu aucune nouvelle par exemple de
l'attaché de presse c'est totalement
terminé du côté des bleus ils se sont
refermées sur leur bulle elles vont
maintenant regagner l'été européen où la
l'accueil s'annonce évidemment très
frais manu est ici en afrique du sud
merci manuel et on vous retrouvera sans
doute tout à l'heure direction l'elysée
maintenant bonsoir michaël darmon vous
êtes en direct thierry henry sera donc
reçu demain par le président la
république qui a eu l'initiative de
cette rencontre et pourquoi nicolas
sarkozy at il décidé de s'engager à ce
point et bien c'est thierry henry à qui
tout de suite après dès la fin du match
contre l'afrique du sud hier à
téléphoner directement présent la
république et lui a demandé audience il
a même fait par deux fois et nicolas
sarkozy aussi a fait remarquer
qu'aujourd'hui que c'est également
thierry henry qui a divulgué
l'information à la presse alors on ne
sait pas ce que vont se dire demain les
deux hommes aient l'impression qui
domine c'est que thierry henry voudrait
jouer sa propre carte
quoi qu'il en soit c'est aujourd'hui que
le chef de l'état est entré dans le jeu
et sur le terrain donc de du football
français en ruines
en réunissant donc les ministres
concernés et en posant comme préalable
comme premier acte à la réorganisation
du football français la démission de
jean pierre escalettes président de la
fédération française de football le
maître mot depuis quelques jours à
l'elysée pour de nombreuses raisons
politiques c'est l'exemplarité et on
voit que le chef de l'état vous bien que
le premier à endosser ce maillot
michaël darmon à l'elysée merci michael
dans un instant rama yade resté
silencieux jusqu'à présent nous en dira
peut-être davantage merci d'être avec
nous juste avant on va s'intéresser à
celui qui incarne l'espoir pour le
football français laurent blanc il
prendre en main l'équipe cet été qui est
il qu'elles sont ses premiers chantiers
aaron en visite à la location
le chantier est immense il va devoir
faire vite dans moins de deux mois
laurent blanc dirigera son premier match
à la tête des bleus une rencontre
amicale le 11 août en norvège et en
septembre déjà les qualifications pour
l'euro 2012 contre la biélorussie puis
la bosnie herzégovine alors tout le
bonheur possible avec cette équipe une
équipe en lambeaux avec laurent blanc 44
ans viendra peut-être l'heure de la
grande lessive
va-t-on revoir en bleu anelka l'exclu de
la bande evra le meneur de la fronde et
les deux anciens gallas et henry même
ribéry est en sursis
ça va certainement beaucoup bougé avec
laurent blanc laurent blanc la confiance
et le respect du haut de ses 97
sélections de ses titres de champion du
monde et d'europe avec les bleus
l'homme dispose d'une aura capable de
faire accepter ses choix
proche de laurent blanc le bordelais
yoann gourcuff en difficulté devrait
retrouver un premier rôle dans cette
sélection à rebâtir il doit prendre
trois quatre joueurs parmi le groupe
essaie de construire et surtout essayer
de bien s'entourer auprès de blanc une
nouveauté un manager général marino
faccioli dirigera le secteur
administratif
côté sportif place à jean louis gasset
son adjoint de toujours et alain
boghossian un risque ap de l'ère
domenech priorité de cette nouvelle
équipe essaie d'aller voir don je les
clubs respectifs tous les joueurs
concernés pour une éventuelle sélection
pour avoir leur étape pour sonder leur
état d'esprit leur motivation cet été
c'est sûr laurent blanc ne prendra pas
de vacances
bonsoir rama yade alors je le disais on
ne vous a pas entendu depuis le fiasco
de l'équipe de france en afrique du sud
d'abord tout simplement qu'est ce que
cela provoque et en vous vous êtes
tristes et choqués par ce qui s'est
passé comme tout le monde
j'ai été très triste d'une belle fête
gâchée en afrique du sud
j'ai été consterné devant tant
d'indignité le maillot national le
maillot français a été bafoué
bien évidemment par des joueurs qui ont
eu un comportement qui dit tout sauf
exemplaire j'ai pensé à notre jeunesse
j'ai pensé aux bénévoles j'ai pensé aux
petits clubs dans nos territoires
j'ai pensé à tous ces gens qui ont
tellement d'admiration pour les joueurs
de l'équipe de france
oui j'en ai ressenti une grande
tristesse et beaucoup de consternation
vous aviez été épinglés après des
déclarations sur le clinquant de l'hôtel
des bleus est en creux il y avait une
critique un peu du comportement de
l'équipe
qu'est ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
finalement j'ai eu raison un peu avant
tout le monde
je m'en garderais bien de dire cela cela
m'attriste en même temps de voir cette
équipe dans cet état je crois que les
joueurs eux mêmes prennent conscience
aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils ont fait
prennent conscience du fait qu'ils
n'étaient pas de simples joueurs de foot
qu'ils étaient les ambassadeurs de notre
pays qu'il représentait la france à
l'étranger et que ce qui s'est passé ça
s'est passé devant le monde entier
d'où le sentiment de honte qui je pense
doit doit les animer aujourd'hui mais
maintenant il faut regarder vers
l'avenir il faut construire il faut
avancer
c'est assez à ce à quoi je me suis
attelée ces dernières ces derniers mois
et encore de manière plus accéléré ces
derniers jours vous aviez prévu un peu
ce qui était en train de se passer
oui c'est cette prévisible et j'ai eu
plusieurs fois dans plusieurs
interventions bien avant le début de la
coupe du monde mis le doigt sur ces
dysfonctionnements et publiquement pour
aix pour me demander me poser cette
question comment se fait-il que autour
de cette équipe de france il y ait tant
de problèmes et que le système fédéral
ne soit pas en capacité d'y répondre
et face à cette question évidemment bon
ça n'a pas été très bien accueillie au
mans je les ai exprimé ses doutes là
aujourd'hui ce cette débâcle est la
preuve qu'il y avait un problème un
problème qui va au delà des hommes qui
va au delà des joueurs de l'équipe de
france et qui concerne tout un système
qu'il faut aujourd'hui refonder alors un
big bang du foot français est très
généraux en octobre qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement jeu d'abord je me
félicite que le prix dans la république
qui a compris la gravité de cette crise
sans soit saisi de cette question c'est
son rôle
bien sûr que c'est son rôle à partager
le football ont pourri
ce n'est que du football michel platini
me dit souvent attention le football
n'est qu'un jeu
mais regardez ses passions entendez
cette colère saut dans la population
avez vous entendu les réactions vu le
désarroi de notre jeunesse des clubs qui
se posent des questions
oui il faut il répondre parce que c'est
une question de société c'est ce qui est
en jeu salle albert camus disait est
président la foule qui aime bien le site
et tout ce que j'ai appris de la vie en
termes de morale je l' ai appris sur un
terrain de football
parce que ce qui se joue là aujourd'hui
c'est non seulement la refonte du
système fédéral il faut aujourd'hui que
ceux qui sont responsables de cette
situation en tirent les conséquences il
faut que jean pierre escalettes
démissionne au delà des hommes il ya un
système il faut que jean pierre
escalettes des missions qu'ils en tirent
les conséquences
à mon avis il faut que les messieurs
voit un projet neuf il faut une équipe
neuve pour porter une nouvelle ambition
footballistique pour la france ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose et
ça j'ai plaidé ce point aussi auprès du
président la république cet après midi
c'est qu'il faut aujourd'hui
effectivement organiser ces états
généraux du football je suis très
heureuse qu'il ait entendu cette requête
sur laquelle je travaille depuis des
mois
pourquoi faire pour que tous ceux qui
ont à s'exprimer qui ont des choses à
dire sur le football français puissent
le faire comme l'a dit présent à public
en toute transparence et le rétro
mullings 10 jours sable et qu'ensuite on
réforme les structures et puis il ya une
troisième chose qui est évident c'est
l'exemplarité
c'est l'exemplarité je vous parlais de
morale tout à l'heure comment se fait-il
que des joueurs de football dont
certains gagnent 900000 euros par mois
passent devant des supporters français
qui ont fait des milliers de kilomètres
jusqu'en afrique du sud pouvoir les voir
ou même un simple signe de leur part et
qu'ils ne reçoivent qu'un différence
comment se fait-il que tant de
dysfonctionnements ait pu se produire
qu'ils aient eu un fonctionnement
autarcique de l'équipe de france en
dehors de la fédération sans qu'à aucun
moment le système est plus beau char
récupérer non la charte tous avaient la
charge des joueurs ça existe déjà ou
toulouse a été foulée au pied par les
joueurs
c'est pas la solution aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut faire c'est refonder le
système avec une nouvelle équipe avec un
nouveau projet sportif ce qu'il faut
faire c'est dans la formation sportive
des joueurs de l'équipe de france il ya
un volet civique
vous savez il ya indépendants parmi mes
consultations que j'ai vu ces derniers
jours j'ai eu un responsable du football
au téléphone qui me disaient mais vous
rendez vous compte
on leur dit dans la formation de se
tenir droit mais à aucun moment est
plutôt je dirais et on leur dit vous
n'êtes même pas obligé de chanter la
marseillaise mais il faut qu il la
chante la marseillaise parce qu'ils
représentent les valeurs l'image
l'identité de la france
ça c'est l'excès pour l'exemplarité et
je suis aussi soulagé parce que ça c'est
une proposition sur laquelle je
travaille ces derniers jours que il est
accepté de même que les primes sponsors
d'un montant de 5 millions d'euros ne
soit pas perçue par eux et par eux les
joueurs
moi j'avais même plaidé pour que ils
soient reversées aux amateurs et je vous
dirais même une chose en plus
sachant qu' il ya une baisse des
dotations aux amateurs ce contre quoi
d'ailleurs je me suis élevé auprès de la
fédération et bien yare et qu'il irait
équilibrage à faire pour que les
amateurs les petits clubs livre les 4
millions de bénévoles dans le football
en france puissent travailler décemment
parce que moi je les rencontre dans nos
territoires je vois à quel point ils
sont obligés de prendre leur propre
voiture pour amener les gamins sur les
terrains de football le week end et ça
c'est plus possible
il y à une unité du système
footballistique français qu'il faut
préserver cette organisation est
absolument indispensable
on vous a confié et puis je pense aussi
un dernier point qui me semble très
important se posera aussi la question du
fonctionnement des fédérations dans leur
ensemble et ça aussi le présent
l'artiste fera aussi des chantiers nous
sommes au travail il s'agit de restaurer
l'honneur de la france
et croyez bien que le gouvernement est
totalement mobilisée pour cela parce
qu'effectivement le foot c'est un jeu
c'est vrai mais c'est toujours un peu
plus que du fond vous a compris états
généraux en octobre merci rama yade de
nous avons réservé vos premières
déclarations autres titres de
l'actualité ce nouvel élément qui tombe
mal pour eric woerth dans l'affairé
bettencourt en apprend que le ministre
avait décoré de la légion d'honneur
le gestionnaire de la fortune de liliane
bettencourt patrice de maistre
c'était en 2008 et son épouse florence
woerth venait alors d'être embauché par
ces sociétés de gestion pour ceux qui ne
sont pas familiers de ce dossier voici
précisément ce qui fait polémique
explication a mûri libérables des wesh
un couple dans la tourmente
chaque jour ou presque les époux woerth
doivent affronter une nouvelle polémique
dans l'affairé bettencourt
il est aujourd'hui question d'une légion
d'honneur
une décoration remise à cet homme
patrice de maistre le gestionnaire de la
fortune de l'est
yann bettencourt mais aussi l'employeur
de florence woerth
c'est le ministre du budget de l'époque
qu'il a personnellement décoré
y at il eu conflit d'intérêts eric
woerth a répondu cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
écoutez franchement ça devient un peu
n'importe quoi comme tous les ministres
je remets des décorations c'est pour ces
raisons que j'ai remis la légion
d'honneur à monsieur de maistre et que
je l ai remis à d'autres personnalités
comme vous tous l'avait fait mais
derrière cette légion d'honneur pointe
une autre polémique le ministre est il
intervenu pour faire embaucher son
épouse florence woerth a rejoint la
société gérant la fortune bettencourt en
novembre 2007 dans des écoutes
clandestines révélé la semaine dernière
patrice de maistre laissé entendre que
cette embauche avait été faite à la
demande d'eric woerth démenti très
fermes du ministre et de son épouse
me connaissant loi et connaissant mon
mari quand même depuis 30 ans c'est que
ça n'a jamais été le type de relation
que nous avons pu avoir déjà entre nous
et avec des gens de l'extérieur encore
moins pour clore la polémique florence
woerth a annoncé sa démission mais
pouvait-elle ignorer les soupçons de
fraude fiscale
planant sur la gestion de la fortune de
liliane bettencourt
la gauche a son idée 6 milliards de
fortune 40 millions d'impôts en moyenne
par an
on voit bien que ce n'est pas le pas
donc même un élève de troisième se
serait rendu compte qu'il y avait un
mystère
la députée que florence woerth attaqué
en diffamation demandent la démission du
ministre du travail
mais en pleine réforme des retraites
eric woerth a reçu le soutien du premier
ministre et du président de la
république et ces nouveaux éléments
interviennent alors qu'eric woerth est
en première ligne vous le savez dans la
réforme des retraites ce sera demain
l'un des moments de vérité pour les
syndicats qui appellent à une nouvelle
journée de grève et de mobilisation elle
a commencé il ya quelques minutes
à quoi faut-il s'attendre yves jacques
est attristant le braz des passagers au
compte gouttes dès ce soir à la sncf le
trafic devrait sérieusement ralentir les
usagers sont plus ou moins compréhensifs
les gens du travail ils ont qu'à
travailler et puis voilà c'est tout nous
on travaille et puis on fait pas de
grève pour les retraites c'est quelque
chose d'important et on est en train de
supprimer des acquis sociaux un petit
peu à la peine en ce moment donc je
pense qu'il faut se battre pour les
garder je juge pas en fait chacun défend
ses droits comme hiver
dans le détail la sncf annonce en
moyenne un tgv sur deux en circulation
les corail 1 train sur 4 seulement en
régions un ter sur deux en ile de france
moins d'un transilien sur 2 pour les
métros parisiens les usagers aussi
devront patienter 60% des rames
circuleront les rer seront très
perturbés
surtout la ligne b en revanche pour les
bus et des tramways le trafic sera quasi
normal
en province des préavis de grève ont été
déposés dans 65 réseaux de transports
urbains
toutes les villes grandes et moyennes
devraient être touchés quant au
transport aérien 85% des vols devraient
être assurés au départ d'orly et de
roissy dans l'éducation d'après les
syndicats la moitié des professeurs du
primaire n'assurera pas les cours
certaines administrations comme la poste
ou encore des banques pourraient être
affectées bonsoir valérie le rouge vous
êtes en direct à la gare montparnasse à
paris pourquoi la sncf qui n'est pas
directement concerné par cette réforme
est elle aux avant-postes dans cette
grève demain certes david les cheminots
ne seront pas concernés
dès 2011 en tout cas comme la plupart
des français du régime général ou de la
fonction publique mais ils ont bien
compris qu'à moyen terme en tout cas
cette réforme aura bel et bien des
conséquences sur leur retraite
aujourd'hui ils peuvent quitter leur
travail à 55 ans eh bien ce sera
progressivement 57 ans c'est-à-dire deux
ans de plus comme tout le monde
seule différence ce sera à partir de
2017 pour eux contre l'année prochaine
pour tout le monde
alors eh bien ce n'était pas aussi clair
il y à un mois lors de la première grève
d'ailleurs elle avait été peu suivi
entre temps le gouvernement a précisé sa
réforme les syndicats entendent bien en
profiter pour mobiliser le plus possible
demain dans les gares et dans les dépôts
pour perturber le plus des transports et
pour peser davantage dans le débat
valérie le rouge à paris merci valérie
toujours à propos d' économie cette
décision qui se veut symbolique en ces
temps d'austérité et de controverses
aussi sur les avantages des élus ou des
ministres la traditionnelle garden party
du 14 juillet à l'elysée est supprimé
son coût était estimé l'an dernier à
quelque 730 milles
alexandre karajan moines de toutes les
garden party celle de 1998 fut peut-être
la plus mémorable
en 2010 il n'y aura ni coupe du monde ni
garden pas là nicolas sarkozy aurait
décidé de supprimer le traditionnel
rendez vous du 14 juillet pour cause de
crise pour raison d'économies en 2009
sept mille cinq cents invités se sont
retrouvés dans les jardins elysées pour
un coût total de 730 2008 126 euros
parmi les postes de dépenses et traiteur
plus de 300000 euros les installations 2
195 milles où les vins et champagnes
plus de 40000 euros est en période de
crise
je pense que si on doit montrer
l'exemple la suppression de la garden
party ça va dans le bon sens la veille
d'une manifestation pour la défense des
retraites
on en est rendu à des artifices et pas
730 1000 euros économisés
c'est des dizaines de milliards d'euros
la garden party une institution créée
par valéry giscard d'estaing prises et
également par ses successeurs
françois mitterrand ou jacques chirac
chaque année l'occasion d'inviter des
célébrités des notables des militaires
ou de simples citoyens champagne petits
fours orchestre une réception digne des
fastes de la république à l'ancienne
avant la garden party nicolas sarkozy
avait déjà décidé de supprimer le
concert du 14 juillet il faut dire
l'an dernier le spectacle donné par
johnny hallyday avait provoqué la
polémique avec sa facture de plus de 3
millions d'euros
autre information ce soir françois
fillon a indiqué que le secrétaire
d'état christian blanc devra payer sur
ses deniers personnels la totalité de
ces dépenses en cigares
elle s'élève selon matignon à 12000
euros c'est le canard enchaîné qui avait
révélé l'histoire plusieurs de ces
affaires ont alimenté la chronique
récemment avantages en nature notes de
frais indues ou emplois de complaisance
enquête sur ce que l'on appelle parfois
les fromages de la république c'est le
dossier de cette édition
il est signé jeff vite imbert pascal
caron ne dites surtout pas à roger
karoutchi qu'il a pris une retraite
dorée comme ambassadeur de france auprès
de l' ocde
les éléphants un peu secoués l'ancien
secrétaire d'état nommée ici par nicolas
sarkozy veut le faire savoir
ici on travaille 70 heures par semaine
nous précise steve voiture de fonction
officiers de sécurité environ 4000 euros
par mois plus les avantages roger
karoutchi qui représente la france à
l'organisation de coopération et de
développement économiques ne se voit pas
on privilégie jardins jardins jardin
j'ai pas de machin j'ai rien j'ai même
pas une chaise longue
rien certains les appellent les fromages
de la république autrement dit les bons
fauteuil octroyés par l'état par exemple
l'institut du monde arabe présidée par
dominique baudis ou la cité nationale de
l'histoire de l'immigration avec jacques
toubon à sa tête
leur liste est très longue en 68 le
percement du tunnel sous le mont blanc
le mon plan à créer une fonction aussi
haute que le sommet lui-même la
présidence de la société du mont blanc
edouard balladur fut le premier
président toutes ces présidences et ses
fonctions sont loin d'être fictive
certaines le sont devenus le socialiste
rené dosière en a recensé un bon nombre
des postes devenus inutiles aujourd'hui
de la ville de paris un titre une
rémunération qui n'est pas négligeable
mais aucun travail à effectuer et dans
lequel les majorités successives de
gauche comme de droite nommé
ouf on leur a mis un fromage
véritablement et ceux qui le plus
discuté aujourd'hui c'est le cumul des
fonctions et des rémunérations
jean jacques aillagon l'ancien ministre
de la culture président
le château de versailles une énorme
machine avec ses 1000 salariés il
perçoit 12000 euros mensuels mais s'y
ajoute une indemnité de 3000 euros
en tant que membre du conseil économique
et social demande beaucoup de temps
votre statut de membre du conseil
économique et social coûte et j'ai tenté
d'être très assidus à ma responsabilité
j'ai même tenu à être l'auteur d'un
rapport sur le patrimoine de notre vie
sur le patrimoine monumental dans le
pays donc sur un sujet que je connais
bien mais qu'ils ne revoient m'a demandé
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail
il s'appelle en fait le conseil
économique social et environnemental il
compte 233 membres parce qu'il ya eu des
dérives dans le passé georgette lemaire
par exemple la chanteuse avait dé nommer
une commission par françois mitterrand
le conseil a mauvaise presse
on ne vient pas ici se reposer dans les
exemples plus grands c'est sans doute la
création du rennie il est né ici avec le
père brzezinski avec geneviève anthonioz
de gaulle et atd quart monde c'est ici
qu'on l'a sensibilisé la nation aux gens
les plus meurtris par la vie
l'ancien député ps marie noëlle
lienemann spécialiste du logement et
celle n est également membre du conseil
économique et social
elle reverse son salaire et côté
avantages simplement des remboursements
de chez la carte navigo france le
conseil économique et social à sa
chorale elle n'a pas son répertoire le
refrain sur les privilégiés de la
république et dans ce contexte c'est un
avertissement que vient d'adresser
didier migaud le nouveau président de la
cour des comptes au gouvernement pour
son premier rapport l'ex député
socialiste s'alarme de la dérive des
finances publiques
pour lui les mesures annoncées sont très
insuffisantes le redressement impliquera
une augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires images frédéric bonne il
est 20 heures et 22 minutes rester avec
nous à suivre la france interdite
officiellement les biberons contenant du
bisphénol a
ce composé chimique pourrait provoquer
des maladies graves comme en comptait
plus d'un milliard d'habitants le plus
grand recensement jamais entrepris au
monde a commencé en inde y compris dans
les zones rebelles
et puis yes week-end ils l'ont fait eux
aussi retour au football les etats unis
se sont qualifiés à la dernière minute
les anglais auront eux aussi en
huitièmes de finale
d'abord donc cette interdiction
officielle de la france concernant la
fabrication et la vente de biberons en
plastique contenant du bisphénol a
depuis des années les scientifiques
soupçonnent l'implication de ce
composant chimique dans des maladies
graves
nicolas chateauneuf sébastien laffargue
explications il peut être en verre ou en
plastique mais désormais le biberon
c'est sans bisphénol a un nom barbare
pour cette molécule chimique qui rentre
dans la composition de nombreux objets
du quotidien film alimentaire canettes
de boisson intérieur des boîtes de
conserve
le bisphénol a est partout cet
après-midi le parlement a interdit la
vente et la fabrication des biberons qui
en contiennent
mais l'interdiction porte seulement sur
les biberons ce qui fait bondir
certaines associations on va protéger
les nourrissons qui sont nourris avec un
aller passer par un biberon mais on ne
va pas protéger les nourrissons qui sont
nourris au sein maternel donc totalement
incohérent or le lait maternel est plus
contaminés que le lait qui est passé par
un biberon les chercheurs suspectent le
bisphénol a dans gendre et des
perturbations hormonales pouvant
favoriser le diabète les maladies
cardiovasculaires et les troubles de la
reproduction des études sont encore en
cours pour évaluer son impact exact chez
l'homme en attendant leurs résultats
dans le monde deux pays ont interdit le
bisphénol a non seulement dans les
biberons mais aussi dans tous les
plastiques alimentaires
le canada et le danemark à l'étranger
c'est un coup dur pour l'armée
américaine en plein conflit en
afghanistan le général en chef des
opérations stanley mcchrystal vient
d'être limogé par barack obama dans des
propos rapportés par le magazine rolling
stone il avait dénigré ou plaisanté à
propos de ses supérieurs
bonsoir maryse burgot vous êtes en
direct de washington c'est un coup de
tonnerre là bas oui vous avez raison
david c'est un coup de tonnerre
barack obama vient d'ailleurs tout juste
de s'exprimer avec à ses côtés le
général petraeus qui remplacera
désormais le général mcchrystal alors
barack obama n'avait finalement guère le
choix s'ils n'avaient pas limogé ce
général il serait apparu comme un faible
comme un président capable d'accepter
l'insubordination d'un militaire ce
n'était pas politiquement pas possible
de passer l'épongé imaginer mcchrystal
et ses collaborateurs ont ouvertement
critiqué barack obama ils l'ont décrit
comme un être intimidé devant les
militaires intimider ce n'était tout
simplement pas acceptables pour barack
obama qui a donc finalement décidé de
limoger mcchrystal cette histoire
illustre en tout cas le fossé qui existe
en ce moment entre les militaires et les
civils de l'administration obama
maryse burgot aux états unis merci
maryse pour ses explications
toujours aux états unis la fuite de
pétrole repart malheureusement de plus
belle dans le golfe du mexique
l'entonnoir qui permettait de pomper une
partie du brut est l'origine de la marée
noire a été retiré après
une fuite de gaz l'inde est elle la
nation la plus peuplée du monde le pays
a décidé de lancer un gigantesque
recensement pour conter une population
encore très mal connu deux millions
d'agents sont en train de sillonner le
territoire reportage pierre monnet gier
dominique marault tél ils sont plus d'un
milliard mais combien exactement
personne ne le sait comment compter
cette foule qui grossit de 50 mille âmes
chaque jour ces millions de migrants
permanent cette population insaisissable
c'est la mission d'hommes comme par
ville q marc ici c'est particulièrement
difficile parce qu'il y a des gens qui
viennent de tout le pays et qui parle
tellement de dialectes différents
cette ville champignon accueille les
expulser des bidonvilles de délits
souvent oubliée lors des précédents
recensements cette fois ci 2 millions de
fonctionnaires sont lancés dans le plus
grand porte à porte de l'histoire pour
qu'aucun indice ne manque à l'appel
toute la famille est ici six personnes
dans dix mètres carrés pas d'eau
courante
une situation encore très fréquentes en
inde tout comme l'illettrisme qui
complique la tâche des compteurs moi je
le sais ni lire ni écrire
je ne comprends rien à leurs papiers à
ce qu'il me demande souvent les gens ont
peur ils pensent qu on vient les
expulser s'ils sont là c'est plutôt pour
les intégrer à la société indienne de
2010 j'avais la radio non la télé oui
vous êtes de quel castes les qualités
ils sont de la caste des bergers c'est
une basse caste donc on va le noter
c'était abou interdit depuis 1931
aucun recensement n'a fait mention de la
caste aujourd'hui ces citoyens de
seconde zone sont à nouveau répertoriés
mais selon ce démographe
il ne s'agit pas d'un retour en arrière
au contraire cela va permettre de lutter
contre les discriminations
grâce à ces chiffres on va pouvoir
lancer des mesures pour faire reculer
les inégalités et d'ailleurs ce sont les
castes les plus basses qu'ils ont
réclamées mais l'inde de 2010 c'est
surtout entre les basses castes et les
milliardaires
une classe moyenne de plusieurs
centaines de millions de personnes
ce sont eux qui tirent la croissance
alors le gouvernement ne recule devant
rien pour percer leur intimité revenus
loisirs niveau d'étude tout y passe en
échange et c'est une première
chaque indien recevra une carte
d'identité
cette carte d'identité ça va m'aider ne
serait ce que pour ouvrir un compte en
banque
d'après certaines estimations l'inde
pourrait frôler le milliard 300 millions
d'habitants
les résultats seront publiés dans un peu
moins d'un an avec un objectif non
affichés talonnés voire dépassé l'âge il
est devenir prêtre le pays le plus
peuplé au monde
en bref encore à l'étranger en jamaïque
christopher co parrain présumé de la
drogue a finalement été arrêté l'homme
âgé de 42 ans est sous le coup vous le
savez d'une demande d'extradition des
états unis
sa traque rappelons le avait provoqué le
mois dernier des violents affrontements
à kingston entre la police et des gangs
armés faisant au moins 73 morts
carnet blanc le prince albert ii de
monaco s'est fiancé aujourd'hui avec sa
compagne la sud africaine charlene
wittstock de vingt ans sa cadette une
officialisation dans la plus stricte
intimité du palais la date du mariage
n'a pas encore été dévoilé retour au
football maintenant côté compétition
cette fois vous l'avez vécu en direct
sur france 2 cet après midi les
américains ont parachevé leur
qualification dans les arrêts de jeu
pour les huitièmes de finale
l'angleterre sera aussi la partie
christophe duchiron comme d'habitude du
point de vue cosmétique les américains
ont eu la main lourde sur le maquillage
un support terrien qui maquillée comme
une voiture volée réclame un but et une
victoire qui qualifierait les états unis
pourtant face à l'algérie longtemps
l'america trembler les américains jouent
à fond et en tunique blanche les
américains ont tiré autant de fois qu un
shérif dans un western
mais à chaque fois c'est comme si le
shérif ratait la cible à par elvis ans
ronflent hackett les américains n'ont
pas la banane le brushing de bill
clinton fait la tête
les autres ne sont plus seulement dans
les tribunes du stade mais dans les
travées d'une église
ils prient pour une amérique triomphante
on peut penser ce qu'on veut des
religions mais alors que les deux
équipes sont dans le temps additionnel
presque au bout du bout du match
l'américain donovan vaste sur le but qui
qualifie l'amérique pour les huitièmes
de finale
la suite et chorégraphique mais c'est
moins maîtrisé qu'à las vegas au même
moment l'algérie verse une larme
dans l'autre match face à la slovénie
l'angleterre en rouge a gagné 1 0 ce qui
lui assure la deuxième place du groupe
derrière les états unis
les anglais peuvent remercier germaine
quartier germaine de faux et qui a
marqué le seul but de la rencontre
et j'ajoute que des incidents ont éclaté
en fin d'après midi après la défaite de
l'algérie c'était aux abords du stade
charléty à paris ou le match contre les
états unis étaient retransmis en direct
sur écran géant une vingtaine de
voitures ont été renversées ou brûlées
des affrontements ont eu lieu avec les
forces de l'ordre avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres l'équipe de france de
football est en train de quitter
l'afrique du sud florent malouda était
parti le premier sans dire un mot
nicolas sarkozy s'empare du dossier il
annonce des états généraux du football
sur ce plateau tout à l'heure rama yade
secrétaire d'état aux sports se
prononcer pour un big bang dans la
fédération et une nouvelle équipe à la
tête des instances du football français
merci à vous tous tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko nous promet encore du
beau et du show 20h35 un téléfilm
vérités assassines avec zabou breitman
et michèle bernier à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr